as hurricane Harvey batters Texas and
rescue workers do their best to mitigate
the enormous damage President Trump
deftly sidesteps the tsunami of negative
press that the mainstream media have
been waiting to unleash again since this
time 12 years ago
plus finally once again roaming
millennial Amanda presto Giacomo and
Nike Jared joined the panel of
deplorable z' to discuss Amazon's Whole
Foods price cut Obama's soon to be
deported dreamers and a new study on the
best ways to buy happiness
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
well everybody happy national bowtie day
it is you may have noticed a little
something different about my appearance
this one was given to me by a Republican
political operative buddy of mine bill
in New York I think he got it at the
Union League club there which is a
conservative Club and I say I think that
all men should know how to tie a bowtie
it is a skill that any good gentleman
should know and you should use that
skill very rarely or else you've become
like Bill Nye or something
Bill Nye they're not very scientific guy
so a happy national boat today I hope
you all celebrate as well and I also
have to thank a little bit of news over
the weekend we were off we didn't have a
show on Friday and I came home on Friday
I never checked my mail so my mailbox is
stuffed with like a hundred Wall Street
journals and letters and stuff and
there's a letter in there from the White
House there's a letter from so I open it
up and it's from President Trump
actually he was thanking me for my
literary contribution and I think the
letter said congratulations on your
success keep up the good works we thank
you president Trump a true supporter of
scholarship and fine literature I really
appreciate it and speaking of President
Trump and doing a good job
we have his response to hurricane Harvey
so just in short I'm sure you've all
been seeing news clips and reading about
it this has been truly a catastrophe
it's been even worse than anyone
predicted there are six people confirmed
dead already but rescue workers haven't
even gotten to the hardest hit parts of
Houston and other parts of Texas Houston
is expected to get a total of 50 inches
of rain that's a that's an annual total
in two or three days they got 20 inches
of rain within 24 hours there have there
more than 3,000 National Guard troops
deployed already 130 mile an hour winds
and President Trump will travel to Texas
on Tuesday so he'll travel tomorrow
now the similarities between this and
hurricane katrina are pretty eerie
actually Hurricane Katrina happened
almost 12 years to the day before
hurricane Harvey did the Katrina was on
August 29th Harvey's on August 25th both
presidents were on vacation President
Trump was at Camp David as this was
happening the media have both been
waiting to pounce on the presidents for
things that are beyond their control
they're both ready to criticize all of
the verbal responses so last week before
going to Camp David President Trump was
asked if he had last-minute advice for
Texas before the hurricane made landfall
this was his response
it audios a little bit hard to hear but
he's asked as he's walking to the
helicopter he's asked do you have any
advice for the people of Texas he says
good luck just a perfectly reasonable
thing to say except that the president
is expected to give grand statements of
spiritual consolation and you know
high-minded advice and that's just not
what this president is for this
president is a guy who just goes into
deregulation he's a guy who's moving
around all of his his administrators
he's a guy who's in the weeds in the
politics but he doesn't really rise up
to this great moral speaker in a way
that we've come to expect from
presidents you know President Obama was
sort of the opposite all he would do is
give these grandiose speeches and he
couldn't actually accomplish anything
through his own policies or through
pushing legislation so he's been roundly
criticized for saying that you could see
the mainstream media had their fangs out
to just rip this guy to shreds you know
president from has asked what to say to
Texas he says good luck you know is
everywhere Washington Post Politico ran
a piece that was very honest about the
political perils of this storm knowing
what happened to President Bush and
Hurricane Katrina so you remember during
Hurricane Katrina here was President
Bush's response just a few days after
he'd been criticized for his lack of a
response to the natural disaster
Americans have every right to expect a
more effective response in a time of
emergency when the federal government
fails to meet such an obligation I as
president am responsible for the problem
and for the solution so President Bush
as always he's taking responsibility
even when it isn't exactly his
responsibility to take the troubles with
Katrina were largely failures of local
government of Democrats who destroyed
that city who didn't prepare for these
storms didn't have sufficient levees to
keep the water out and and the federal
government did respond he was criticized
for not going to Louisiana which he said
he didn't do because he didn't want to
cause more trouble there and make it
more difficult to lead the recovery
efforts nevertheless this still wasn't
enough
then we got the most famous criticism of
President Bush's response from that
famed
that world renowned psychologist Kanye
West just to imagine if I was if I was
down there and those are those are my
people down there anybody out there that
wants to do anything that we can help
with with the set up the way America is
set up to help the the poor the the
black people the the less well-off as
slow as possible I mean this is Red
Cross is doing everything they can
we already realized a lot of the people
that could help are at war right now
fighting another way and they've given
them permission to go down and shoot us
George Bush doesn't care about black
people please call Mike Mike Meyers
this is response they're looking at
ganya what poor guy like did I stood
yeah like a train just hit him and of
course there's the ever eloquent Kanye
West I'm not they say that too right
well is to think clearly that's why it's
so hard
I think the same might be true of
speaking so anyway none of this was
enough for President Bush he I made the
right decision not to go to New Orleans
and not to further add to the chaos
President Trump is not making these
mistakes he is he has clearly learned
from his predecessor he knows the media
if President Bush was the the worst at
maneuvering around the mainstream media
of any modern president President Trump
is he's a creature of it he was made for
it he he is the media I think that's why
he's so good at navigating through them
so what's he doing now he's tweeting
he's tweeting a lot he knows he's
unlikely to get a fair shake in the
press so he's gonna write the story
himself he sent out 22 tweets in the
last few days himself about hurricane
Harvey and then for retweets of local
officials and other federal officials
Pruitt and Vice President pence the vast
majority of his Twitter timeline is him
talking about hurricane Harvey we get as
hurricane Harvey intensifies to remember
to plan ahead I have spoken with
Governor Abbott of Texas Louisiana
governor Edwards closely monitoring
hurricane RV you can't tell me I'm not
monitoring I told you myself
I received a hurricane Harvey briefing
this morning I encourage everyone in the
the per akane harvey to heed the advice
just arrived at Camp David where I am
closely watching the path and doings of
hurricane Harvey be safe in that
wonderful trumpian fashion for all caps
and an exclamation point on and on we
will remain fully engaged with open
lines of communication to ensure your
safety ahead of Harvey heed the warnings
he's repeating himself even but he will
not be accused of not paying attention
to this and of letting the this disaster
consumed the local area without a
federal response the mainstream media or
furious they are furious that he's
handling this well so Vox tweeted out a
headline president Trump's response to
hurricane Harvey devastation Wow
Trump's bowled over by Harvey's size and
scale not its impact on victims
absolutely ridiculous in one of these 26
tweets he used the word wow to describe
an unprecedented hurricane in Texas I
think that's fair enough and if that
were in an upper box they said here's
when President Trump's response to
hurricane Harvey will really matter
whatever he says while it's unfolding
matters far less than what he does in
the coming weeks they're basically
admitting we were hoping that this guy
would screw it up while it's happening
just like President Bush did he didn't
so now we have to say that doesn't
really matter even though three days ago
they said that he needed a robust
response while it was happening that
good luck wasn't enough so now they're
saying we just need to watch the coming
weeks that is not enough and all of this
misses the point a little bit on the
difference between the federal
government and the state and local
governments this is a regional issue
it's a state issue so we're all turning
to the president to see how the federal
government is going to react really I
think this undercuts a lot of the
federalism and the principles of limited
government that we constantly are
talking about on the right CNN Believe
It or Not CNN which John Nolte assures
me is Hitler and Isis CNN was shockingly
somewhat honest in their headline today
they said quote I know this is this is a
truly a magical day maybe we've all just
been wiped into the apocalypse and where
we're seeing the impossible the quote
Trump meeting and tweeting his Harvey
moment so CNN is acknowledging Trump is
really rising to the occasion here
he's plugged in he's being serious in
his response he's not yelling at
celebrities here something is being
Ernest and he's actually talking to
officials and and broadcasting that for
all of us they had to get that little
jibe in that he's tweeting about it but
the only reason he's tweeting about it
is because you guys wouldn't give him a
fair shake if he didn't if he didn't
have that direct line of communication
to the American people all we would be
hearing is a replay of 2005 and Donald
Trump doesn't care about black D I don't
know how many black people there aren't
Houston but Donald Trump doesn't care
about Texans or something like that and
fortunately for him and for us on the
right and his Americans he is able to
sidestep those Democrat hacks with that
we have to bring on our panel this is a
very special day this is the longest
that I have gone since launching my show
without speaking to roaming millennial
it has been hell I have the shakes I've
been in withdrawal we have roaming
millennial back we have Amanda presto
Giacomo from The Daily wire back we just
had her in studio last week and not gay
Jared the one and only not gray Jared
host of the morning grinders and he's on
some other guys show with some kind of
mug or side I don't forget the details
roaming what role hanko has what role is
the tweeting played in this news cycle I
think it's actually been really smart of
Trump to say like you said almost not
overdo it but just really make sure to
cover all his bases make sure that there
is no way that anyone can accuse him of
not taking this seriously or you know
trying to sidestep this I mean I think
if the Charlottesville incident kind of
taught him anything it's that he needs
to be you know almost shove it down
these people's throats like what he
thinks what he cares about and so as
always with this Twitter I think he has
this great tool to just reach out to
people and kind of even cite stuff any
of the need to go through the media to
communicate with his base and even
people who are critical of him and I
think you know there have been some
rough instances of his Twitter use but
this is an instance where he's actually
done a good job in my opinion that's
right and he hasn't tweeted very much
about Charlottesville in he was
basically silent about it until he gave
that statement and it seemed to come
back and bite him do you think he should
have used Twitter during Charlottesville
to you know what I was someone who
I was satisfied with his initial
condemnation of all violence hatred and
bigotry and I was further satisfied by
his explicit condemnation of neo-nazis
in the KKK and that you would allow that
kind of racist rhetoric you know kind of
taking him as at his word it's this new
thing but you know he actually did I
think initially tweet out at least one
thing you know condemning violence
generally on Twitter but if we look at
people like Paul Ryan Marco Rubio and
you know even someone like Mitt Romney
who were very very vocal about this on
social media they're people who the you
know mainstream media have actually been
praising in regards to this so for I
don't know the leftist elites at least
that is more what they were looking for
but again you know I think there are
people that they're just never gonna
have be happy with anything he does
anyway right so he might as well get his
message out there
Nucky's you're right were the attacks on
Bush during Hurricane Katrina and I know
you were like for during Hurricane
Katrina
I was yeah you can barely remember this
but were the attacks on him fair looking
back on it now through the lens of
hurricane Harvey was it fair or or did
he did he just not fight back against an
unfair media narrative I think Trump
really has paved the way for the
pushback I don't know that's such a
different world we live in now compared
to back then you know there was no
Twitter for for Bush to take advantage
of - right - you know get his message
out there I don't know I think gosh how
old would I have been I would have been
15 15 all this happens so for me to look
back at through the lens of today it's
not only just warped and so different
radically different the way the media is
I think the the presentation the
pushback that we as conservatives have
on the consume media just it didn't
exist I would have liked
in hindsight to see Bush maybe he's
pushed back a lot more and not take you
know the blame for things that maybe
weren't his fault but that's difficult
one I don't know 2017 changes everything
change the lens of you can try to force
history through that lens it becomes
really weird and awkward place kind of
like I was in a funeral not out looking
at the news certainly I know you that's
a great point we are hitting bush a lot
I think because he didn't fight back he
never pushed back on the media all of
these awful Bush lied people died no war
for oil all
lies that they promoted but the question
is how would he have fought back you
know Donald Trump is a creature of
reality TV that he essentially made
himself and back then there was no real
direct line of communication that's true
we might be a little unfair to mr.
George W Bush Amanda very like can you
imagine if there would have been Bush
Twitter though I mean we kind of missed
out on something potentially great there
I hear a Netflix series in them I don't
think you would have given Gale in the
media quite the gifts Trump does though
sometimes so when you know when Trump
does come out I had a problem it was it
yesterday Sunday Saturday Trump came out
tweeted something about his winning big
Lee in Missouri kind of tweets I do
think Trump needs to be careful with not
handing the media they're not gonna let
me win no matter what but when you hand
them gifts when they say you're the
dumbest president in the history of the
presidency and you come out stare
directly into the Sun that's a gift
don't give the media gifts to run with
because it's it's it's it's not helping
you at all it so it takes away from the
things he does that are legitimately you
know smart wise strategic moves as a
president it's also literally a gift
it's also literally a movie staring at
the side and again right look at the Sun
still not blind so take that science
absolutely the people heap showed the
opposite of what people were saying he
was showing you know they set out there
he doesn't believe the fake news so he's
gonna blind himself doesn't look blind
to me looks like he has great vision
vision for a future Amanda why are we so
focused on the federal response here
this is basically a state and regional
issue obviously it's a tremendous state
and regional issue but the federal
government has promised to support state
and local governments why aren't we
looking at the governors why is
everything focused on the president it
was actually a President Bush did a fine
job but it's the local level that
fumbled everything and he got blamed for
it and like we saw in that video clip
george w bush because he's just an
honorable guy took responsibility when
he shouldn't have that wasn't his fault
they were stonewalling him they told him
no like we don't stand down we don't
need you we don't need help they
was terrible they delayed it way too
long that was all their fumble and this
is a local regional thing and now we
look at what's going on in Texas and
there was much better management at the
local and state level and that's why
we're seeing this great success
yes president Trump is offering support
as he should so did George W Bush the
difference is the optics George how much
does that you know I'm sorry it's my
fault Donald Trump goes to his Twitter
feed and shows no I'm doing this as
never doing a great job yeah I mean this
is a local state thing and then of
course the federal government is
therefore supporter but this is more
local than anything else I even found
his good luck to be clearly
well-intentioned and fairly on point
he's not saying having to abandon you in
the storm he's saying this obviously
we're not going to be able to
effectively control disaster relief from
thousands of miles away
so good luck take care of yourselves and
we'll be there when you need to recover
yeah it doesn't matter what we're going
to jump on him anyway so even a good
luck trigger them so absolutely all
right we have to say goodbye now to
Facebook in YouTube it makes me sad it
makes me as sad as it makes you but you
can turn it all around by going to daily
wire.com right now and subscribing it's
$10 a month or $100 a year you get me
Andrew Klavan the ben shapiro show and
the leftist tears tumblr it is the the
only vessel for having your delicious
leftist tears it keeps them hot or cold
always salty and delicious
one thing I love doing I've lost my
earpiece one thing I love doing is
storing my steven crowder mug in the
leftist years tumblr I get to drink them
both it's very very delicious
right now do you wire calm thank you to
everyone who's already subscribing we
appreciate it
we'll be right back
I got so excited by that that I lost my
earpiece came right out of my head
but luckily I think I can still hear you
all will see now I'll just look like a
robot for the rest of the show okay we
need to move on to very important news
Amazon has purchased the overpriced
left-wing yuppie food chain Whole Foods
in recent weeks and on their first day
of operations they have cut prices by 43
percent now I'm very excited because
it's the only place to get broccoli rabe
which is my favorite vegetable and also
because even after selling a blank book
and making a number one in the world I
can't afford to shop at Whole Foods it's
not it's out of my price range so this
is great news as far as I'm concerned
roaming there are a lot of worries about
Amazon having a virtual monopoly tons of
control
but if it'll get us a cheaper fish
should we really care should we worry
about these tech giants amassing all
this power well I think you know
worrying about monopolies in the age
where Google controls pretty much
everything is definitely a legitimate
concern but when it comes to Amazon and
Whole Foods specifically you know there
are so many competitors out there at the
moment I don't think we need to be
worried just yet but I am really curious
about you know all these price cuz
they're doing it's too early to say now
but I I'm really wanting to know what's
going on internally like what kind of
changes they're making to the way the
company is run that they're able to do
this right I mean because I like anyone
you know I want to eat healthy but I
also want to pay out of no rent right so
for the longest time although it's not
like Whole Foods is just like a place
you don't go like a Lamborghini
dealership but now you know I'll get
some of the price drops and yeah it's so
much more affordable and I'm just
wondering how they're doing it like is
this like predatory pricing are they
just trying to you know make everyone go
out of business and then they jack it up
like I'm actually curious as to what's
going on in Whole Foods were they're
managing to make these massive cuts I
wonder that as well the same question
could be true of Amazon but Amazon keeps
this price is relatively low Amanda on
that everybody talks about loving
mom-and-pop shops so nice it's the old
America Main Street but nobody actually
shops there because the prices are too
high should we embrace our corporate
overlords
yeah I'm not I mean I'm not one of these
people who think
all artists evil or any of these big
corporations are evil they hire a lot of
people they help you know people with
lower income to buy goods and services
that said I do wish there were more
people you know supporting local
businesses my growing up my dad had a
local small bakery as fund small
businesses and it just it just you know
that sense of community that we don't
have anymore you know helping your
neighbors and going to your neighbors
store that that would be nice but at the
same token I mean Walmart and you know
now this merger with Amazon with with
Whole Foods they're driving prices down
and that does help consumers and that
does help you know your your options
that for low low price decent quality
goods so it's you know it's a it's a
balance right I don't ever borrow cups
of sugar from my neighbor you know I
don't think anybody stand about forty
years because you can just get a loan
from Amazon to deliver it to you deliver
a whole bag of sugar so much there there
goes the old American community I guess
okay I don't know my neighbor's name
I just realized yeah well is that just
because you're in Asia and you can't
pronounce it or something or do you mean
in America Oh both I I don't know I'm
just yeah I've never had everything I'm
like I should introduce myself to the
neighbors maybe that's awful but I'm
just like oh I don't know what I'm home
it's like doors locked in sweatpants are
wrong you know ya know let's go with mr.
Lee your bearbette yeah and maybe you
know it's roaming I've seen the way some
people post on YouTube and tweet to you
I would just keep the door locked to
keep the gun loaded these guys they're
they're crazy you don't need to be
introducing yourselves to them okay we
have to move on to the fake news in
typically hysterical fashion the New
York Times reports today this is the
headline quote dreamer plan that aided
800,000 immigrants is threatened the
jury the dreamers the dreamer plan for
those eight hundred thousand immigrants
not illegal aliens they're immigrants of
a dubiously legal variety now a former
President Obama's deferred action for
childhood arrivals or daca immigration
plan may not survive legal scrutiny for
the simple reason that it's illegal can
you imagine that roaming is
acha deader than disco I think so and
dreamers and you know even the concept
kind of even more brollies and dreamers
of you know citizenship through birth
that's something that I think a lot of
people are looking at more closely into
how it's affecting immigration patterns
because you know I think everybody
sympathizes with people who were brought
over when they were younger when they
had no choice not a job is not he's a
psychopath he does not sympathize but
you know it wasn't their fault but at
the same time we have to think about
this logically if we do give up all of
these who are you know brought even you
know against their will didn't have a
choice with their parents if we give
them status literally that's just gonna
encourage more people to do it right
because what you're doing is sending a
message to people that hey if you come
here illegally
you know you might still be in trouble
but there's a chance that your child
will be okay and you know America is
probably the number one most wanted
place to come for immigrants and there
are people out there who will take that
chance who will risk themselves being
deported or put in jail just for their
kids to have that legal status so I
think the idea of giving dreamers status
it's just it's very dangerous and that's
that's a very bad precedent it creates
this awful incentive that's only gonna
lead to more crime obviously more and
the the conditions when you cross that
border I think I read some study that
about 80% of women and girls who cross
are sexually assaulted there are a lot
of people are maimed they have to go
through these awful cartels but Amanda
isn't it a little uncompassionate to
deport these kids who they didn't make a
choice to come here they just found
themselves here at the age of two so
they broke the law but you know they
were toddlers isn't it uncompassionate
to ship them back home they've already
built a life here yeah Betsy politically
this is a tough situation this is not
the most politically advantageous thing
to do to support these these children
the daca people who were basically
unconstitutionally given citizenship or
legal status under President Obama and
benefits and such politically it's not
the most savory thing to send them back
but they
roaming of Saget's that's a really
dangerous precedent and a really bad
incentive for the stuff to keep
happening
the President Trump should end the
docker program I know that there's talks
that he's going to try to get the race
at act push through you know to kind and
then like keep Dhaka and place kind of
save that and then put get the raise
actor which would be fantastic just
simply because of the politics of it
there are even Trump supports majority
of Trump supporters who are not like
gung-ho on ending Dhaka who are okay
with with leaving these children here or
these people who are now grown here it's
not the most politically advantageous
thing to do that said I think you got to
get rid of I mean you gotta stop because
it is such a dangerous precedent and it
is unconstitutional we are land applause
it's clearly illegal yeah yeah I never
see that reported by the way you never
see it reported that a plurality or a
majority of Trump supporters don't think
we should just get the kids out right
away because that would up is that
contradict the narrative yeah but Amanda
raises a great point with the raise act
and that's something I hadn't even
thought about but you know if we if
there was an immigration system in place
that favored high-skilled immigrants
that spoke English and you know went to
American universities and you know
higher higher learning institutions you
know there would be a possibility for
these dreamers to just apply for
citizenship naturally or you know
illegal status actually through that
raise eyes because I'm sure you know
many of these people they're they're
skilled they have an education so you
know this is kind of an issue where
perhaps we're not even looking from this
from the right perspective absolutely
sorry go ahead knock hey Jared
oh I would say the problem is to you go
to every leftist the website every help
put website is reporting on dreamers and
in the background you can hear the Sarah
Magoffin music playing trying to for
every every hard-working you know
english-speaking taxpaying educated
dreamer we've got we've got Hosea but
you're stabbing people
so who's new Impella dude he's referring
to a real person by the way in the
studio there is an illegal immigrant
named Jose stabbing in Texas so we're
nerf you know water here as we speak
yeah
exactly but you know miss Millennials
right we do it can't be plan a so I
think what Trump is doing is in kind of
using it as some chips to play with kind
of the Democrats on this thing to say
hey build the wall because either we
yank this program or or nothing it's all
or nothing because if you don't have the
wall if you don't have things in place
that can really curb immigration you
know illegal immigration it doesn't work
because then it does become plain a for
people that's what I would do if I was
over there I would just hop the border
throw my kid and say we're good as
mericans Trump supporters would be okay
with getting money to fund a wall and
having the Rays Act pass so being to
Congress to you know call us around that
and then Trump maybe defers I'm daca
unless I go Trump supporters I'm not
going to be upset I mean the race Act
would be huge it's gonna cap refugees
again it's a system that looks at who we
want we get to choose who comes to our
system it's not just family based on
relatives
it cuts immigration in half so this
would be a huge huge win to kind of as
Jared was saying you know use it as
leverage and I think he couldn't do that
and where we got rid of Doppler right we
were setting to da daaaa yeah apparently
like last a few months ago yeah that's
silly yeah and your point Jared walzwerk
if you if you build institutions and
organizations and physical barriers to
keep people from coming over then you
can talk about daca or the dreamers or
whatever aces and they want to use it's
snowing Michael because if you don't
know this if you build a wall it's
really about the birds have you heard
Jeff Corwin talking about the birds the
birds have a real problem it's gonna
just screw up the ecosystem I know
because Birds apparently can't fly over
a wall I wear my species privilege on my
sleeve it's discussed sometimes i
disgust myself all right now we need to
talk about happiness now that we've
talked about the dreamers and dreaming
we need to talk about happiness a new
study published in the Proceedings of
the National Academy of Sciences reports
that you can buy happiness money spent
on things does not apparently increase
your happiness but money spent on things
that save you time does buy happiness so
it's a great idea and you should save
your pennies now hey Jared is this just
because we're soft and lazy and need
more time to watch TV on the couch
oh gosh I don't know it could be I used
to never think you can buy happiness but
one time I got to write on a yacht
someone else's someone was Onan and I
became a believer you could pretend you
can buy there's a cost for that yacht
and you could buy it and what this is
saying is that it's actually saying if
you buy the yacht it that won't
necessarily make you happier which makes
me a question I deciding but it says if
you buy a vacuum cleaner or a laundry
machine or a dishwasher it will make you
happier because it'll save your time
from doing mundane tasks and roaming it
is this part of a larger trend because
in decadent times like ours we don't
like to do drudgery that characterized
all of humanity until about 60 years ago
so you know Adam pruned the Garden of
Eden right we've always done these kind
of mundane tasks is there something that
we lose by not doing that by farming it
out to our computer our dishwasher or
something well this is a hard question
for me to answer because on the one hand
I think that definitely at the society
as individuals overcoming a lot more I
don't want to stay lazy but yeah lazy
there's a lot of stuff that you know if
there's it's not automated we won't even
think to do ourselves because that's not
the mentality we've been brought up you
know we can either pay someone else to
do it or outsource it the saw wood or
have a computer do it you know on the
other hand I'm very lazy and I like that
about this but you know I think
especially when I look at children who
are I mean I guess generations even
younger I mean they're they're growing
up with without having to do things like
I don't know like even how worried about
landlines right everyone has a cell
phone now you don't even have to worry
about the constraints of a wire and just
just stuff like that I think that well
we're not necessarily happier but I
would say that we are more comfortable
and a lot of people are conflating
comfort with happiness and you know
we're so busy we have so many things to
do now with all of my new
responsibilities of the daily wire if I
don't get a solid 14 hours of sleep I am
useless the next day I can't do my show
and I guess that's pretty much all I'm
doing I need I need that beauty sleep
otherwise I'm gonna look just awful in
national
bowtie day Amanda you are the saltiest
writer at the daily wire I think I think
maybe even including Ben what makes you
happy
what's the key yeah this is gonna sound
really cliche but it's really nice I
enjoy bothering feminists out of that
any money like I get paid to do it
actually make money doing it and it's
just it brings me serious joy I mean it
sounds cliche but I genuinely enjoy you
have this delete this great tumblr you
can catch all those tears and keep them
for yourself Judith you get the time and
the things yeah it's fantastic
that's am it not get your what makes you
happy what club makes me happy 69 for
students at vets or tumblers tumblers
are pretty awesome too I hear I don't
know I can't confirm you know while
we're talking merch I got to say I see
your t-shirt and I can't really read
what is the t-shirt say socialism is for
FIGS
it's for figs and it's like Che Guevara
shirt without a limp wrist that is right
that's right and it's the quickest way
it's not only trigger people but
probably get punched in the face as well
our followers have a national tea and
ladder with Crowder you guys are such a
subtle brush well and now it's coming
soon I believe we have some onesies
coming it's a crap story there's
actually there's actually a checkbox on
them say yes I I am a horrible parent
well I'm but I'm gonna bleach my eyes
whenever you and mr. Crowder start
wearing that roaming what makes you
happy this is gonna sound really petty
but I've gotten to this habit on Twitter
where if there's someone who's trolling
me I like follow them back and then like
not harass them but it's like oh like a
little bit until they block enough I've
had a lot of fun with that recently and
that is extremely petty and I apologize
to anyone who follows me on Twitter
because a lot of the time I'm just
fighting with strangers but yeah I would
have to say you know I've had to choose
something yeah
roaming you just this was a big mistake
because now every single person who
wants you to follow them is going to
start fighting with
on Twitter anyway that's fair enough all
right you guys you have your assignments
listeners guys thank you for being here
Amanda presto Giacomo Nakia Jared and
finally back again roaming millennial
now it's time for my smart glasses and
the final thought
[Music]
endless think pieces have spilt ink over
the question of president Trump's
tweeting it occasionally undercuts his
policy priorities contradicts his
cabinet members and campaign surrogates
even occasionally raises the prospect of
legal trouble but hurricane Harvey
exposes all those worries for mere
trifles president Trump's attention to
the natural disaster and more
importantly coordination with local and
state first responders has been a table
and admirably but we should remember
that President Bush comported himself
relatively well during Hurricane Katrina
as well
despite the utterly failed response of
local governments in a barrage of unfair
negative press the difference today is
that president Trump's side steps the
mainstream media to speak directly to
the American people and show them what
he and his administration are doing
without the filter of Democrat
operatives who masquerade as journalists
that direct communication has even made
the mainstream media in this case bend
the knee and admit that the president is
doing well miracles abound
so keep tweeting mr. president and you
said it once I'll say it again and again
and again despite the constant negative
press
cough fa I'm Michael Moses the Mike
Connell show come back tomorrow we'll do
it all again
[Music]